look at him right here Gotti's he's big
whoa look at the size of that animal
coming right at us I am in Cape Cod
Massachusetts which over the last few
years has become sort of great white
shark central man look at all the seals
now that explains everything doesn't it
Wow I have spent over five months trying
to figure out how to make a photograph
underwater in Cape Cod of great white
sharks right now we are just offshore
here this is the area where the shark
was hunting look at him he's right there
holy God look at him come on man just
just smile come up to the back and I
feeling sure okay
[Music]
what I've done was worked with
researchers who had begun to design seal
decoys as a way of attracting sharks
yeah holy God look at him oh yeah just
DP buzz oh damn
oh yeah oh yeah I had the idea of trying
to modify their decoys with cameras we
created a wireless trigger system
I could remotely fire the camera from
the boat put her in
there's three sharks within our boat
radius here right in here boy is that
nice look at how close he is nice
shallow water kids are freaking out
people have no idea just how close these
sharks are to the beach
I mean you could wade in and bump into
one of these animals we have a shark
coming from the south coming north and
we're going to put one of our research
decoys in and see if we can observe a
predation and what is now about 15 feet
of water there he is he's kind of come
on international there I see him oh holy
yeah uh-huh yes yes yes yes yes yes yes
yes yes yes man right at us I mean he
came right like this man that was sweet
[Music]
we might have a picture that's what I've
been thinking about all went off did
this particular photo it was crystal
clear you can see deep into the animals
eye you can see this this sort of smile
that these sharks have but this animal
also had some scratches on its face that
I can only presume were caused maybe by
an attack on a seal we nicknamed it Mike
Tyson because it had like a face tattoo
I wanted to create this sort of intimate
portrait of one of these animals I
wanted to put a face on this shadowy
creature that has been portrayed as a
monster and show what they look like to
my knowledge this is the first time a
high quality or high-resolution still
photograph of a great white shark in
Cape Cod waters has ever been produced
as ever
me it took many months and you know a
lot of gray hair to figure out how to do
it but but finally was achieved
[Music]
[Music]